alors est-ce un faux pas politiques du
président en tout cas ses opposants se
sont emparés du sujet à l'image du
député la france insoumise françois
ruffin qui plaide pour un référendum sur
le sujet alors 5 g et faut-il un grand
débat c'est l'objet de notre face à face
est avec nous pour en débattre loïc
prud'hommes débuté et la fille de la 3e
circonscription de gironde bonsoir à vos
côtés cyril d'allemands chercheur à
l'institut thomas more
bonsoir messieurs merci d'avoir accepté
de débattre en direct sur rt france
alors on se souvient c'était en juin
dernier il y avait 150 participants sur
la convention citoyenne sur le climat
elle avait été mise en place par le chef
de l'état et elle proposait alors
d'accompagner l'évolution du numérique
pour réduire ces impacts
environnementaux et elle demandait un
moratoire sur la mise en place de la 5g
alors le chef de l'état on se souvient
il avait validé 146 propositions sur 149
il n'avait pas nommé le sujet de la 5g
néanmoins emmanuel macron at il trahi sa
promesse cyril d'allemand bonsoir merci
à ce qu'il a trahi sa promesse non
je ne crois pas sa déclaration a été
beaucoup commentée ce soir d'ailleurs
toute la journée
je pense qu'elles étaient excessives et
qu'elle en fait elle était excessive à
dessein pour créer pour créer cette
polémique
afin de pouvoir masquer d'autres
d'autres problèmes en fait qui sont à
mon sens beaucoup beaucoup plus profond
vous parlez sur sa déclaration de sa
déclaration sur les amish ans c'est bien
cela justement loïc prud'hommes est ce
que cette déclaration elle est un brin
moqueur on le voit bien
mais est ce qu elle est méprisante pour
vous évidemment elle est méprisante et
elle a pour objet d' essayer de
disqualifier toute discussion qui irait
à l'encontre de des belles promesses que
nous fait président d'un cran sur
l'innovation et le progrès est donc
effectivement c'est assez déplorable
d'être à ce niveau-là de discussion sur
un sujet aussi important qui qui
demandent à avoir des choses argumenté
que la population dans son ensemble
puisse donner son avis on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les les sondages
d'opinion le disent les
les français sont plutôt réticents au
déploiement de cette technologie 5g donc
c'est pas digne en tout cas du débat
nécessaire syrie de la loi est ce que
selon vous le chef de l'état veut
empêcher le débat sur cette question
comme on viens de l'entendre à l'instant
en fait à mon sens il y à il y avait des
questions beaucoup plus profonde que
j'ai cette déclaration un petit peu un
petit peu excessive et oui il ya des
choses qui pose souci ya un problème de
souveraineté qui est importante on l'a
vu avec le débat sur your way le fait
aussi que les champions européens
comme ericsson ou nokia fabrique une
grosse partie de leur pièce en chine
donc elle ça c'est un premier un premier
problème il ya aussi le fait que le
modèle économique européen depuis depuis
matrix et pas des cadets exclusivement
sur la consommation et qui fait de
l'europe une vaste zone de libre échange
le marché des smartphones est à maturité
avec un taux d'équipement à 80% il faut
il faut voilà il faut vendre des
smartphones donc il dit ventes des
smartphones des changements technologie
effectivement la 5g et est une
opportunité très intéressante pour
vendre des changes et louis prud'hommes
avant pourrait agir cet argument
économique comment est ce que vous le
recevez aujourd'hui effectivement on
voit que c'est une fuite en avant sur
l'hyper consommation est effectivement
comment nous faire encore consommée
alors que on est aujourd'hui aucun
septembre et fait 28 degrés en journée
on est face à un mur l'écologie
climatique est le seul horizon que nous
donne le président de la république
c'est de consommer toujours plus alors
qu'il est urgent de ralentir en fait
c'est ça que la question qui est posée
aussi par la scène gs que ces modèles de
société qui nous amène dans le mur dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui c'est plus
quelque chose qui va être dans un délai
plus ou moins long on est aujourd'hui
dans ce mur climatique et il faut sortir
absolument de ce modèle du consumérisme
effréné parce que ça n'a aucune
ça n'a aucun intérêt pour améliorer la
vie des gens pour améliorer notre
bonheur personnel l'acmg les objets
connectés
ça n'a aucun intérêt que mon frigo
envoie un sms pour me dire que il faut
que je rachète du beurre ou d'huile et
ça n'a vraiment absolument aucun impact
sur ma qualité de vie ni sur mon bonheur
ressenti et donc on voit comme le disait
l'autre intervenant aussi c'est pour
relancer un marché l'obsolescence aussi
vendre des smartphones mais vendre des
millions d'objets connectés qui auront
des générations de courte vie et on est
encore dans cette spirale absolument
délétère en tout cas qui n'a aucun
aucune conscience de 12 de l'urgence
climatique de l'urgence environnementale
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui si elle d'allemand
je vous donne la parole tout de suite
mais avant je vous lis ces tweets à
celui d'emmanuel macron mais aussi celui
de barbara pour piler on va les voir à
l'antenne alors pas de polémique écrit
emmanuel macron la convention citoyenne
le dit dans son rapport
le numérique est un levier majeur de la
transition écologique à la 5g sera
déployé en pleine transparence avec à
chaque étape toutes les garanties
environnementales et sanitaires ensemble
pour l'écologie du mieux barbara pompili
elle comme le dit la convention
citoyenne
s'il est bien utilisé et développé dans
la transparence le numérique peut être
un levier écologique le rapport publié
aujourd'hui sur la 5 g et la définition
d'une stratégie de ce bris et et
numériques répondent à cette exigence
alors thomass mort finalement là quand
on lit ces deux tweets la 5g et
l'environnement et bien ça semble
compatible
en tout cas pour le gouvernement qu'est
ce que vous en pensez absolument pas de
manière empirique contre la singer jeu
je pense pas que l'on puisse en temps on
est dans une logique on essaye d'imposer
à des débats binaire un soin et pour son
nez comprend fait il a beaucoup de
nuances dans tout ça avoir beaucoup de
retenue si on multiplie les objets
connectés on multiplie forcément dans le
stockage de données qui ont une petite
élite auquel j'ai donné en multiplient
effectivement la consommation électrique
après on sait également que des progrès
technologiques font qu'on peut réduire
cette consommation électrique avec voilà
un système de stockage donné de données
qui est moins gourmand mais bon on peut
pas juste réduire le débat à être pour
être contre par contre on essaye d'en
d'enrobé les choses
les partisans de la 5g veulent faire
croire que ça ça va révolutionner la vie
que tout sera merveilleux il faut un peu
de retenue est évident qu'aujourd'hui la
4g est toujours pas entièrement déployé
les premières licences de 2011 on voit
bien qui est quand même un temps long
pour accompagner ce titre de
développement technologique il reste
encore en france des zones blanches des
zones grises donc des ongles sont pas
couvertes tout simplement par rapport à
la 4g on va déployer la fin jay fra 5 7
8 ans peut-être dix ans pour qu'elle
soit totalement un totalement
opérationnel donc en fait on peut pas
réduire le débat à des arguments pour
contrer fessée c'est un peu un petit peu
ridicule arguments pour ou contre on
peut pas réduire l'aide à vous nous
dites cyril d'allemand et non pas comme
asseman vous présente mes excuses je me
suis trompé un instant en tout cas
regardez françois ruffin lui aussi s'est
emparé du sujet le député donc de la
france insoumise de lasseube
il a plaidé vie dans l'obs pour un
référendum on va regarder son tweet
alors voilà donc on voit l'instant je
veux un référendum sur la 5g loïc
prud'hommes c'est ça que vous demandez
aujourd'hui
écoutez je voudrais juste qu'on veut
dire que les truites que vous a montré
de la république de barenton chili il ya
une confusion entre le développement du
numérique et la scène g et le pseudo
progrès je pense que la question de mon
collègue françois ruffin de demander un
référendum c'est bien cette question là
nous sommes pour le progrès nous sommes
pour eux le fait que le numérique puisse
apporter effectivement des réponses à
des problèmes que nous avons jaune
aujourd'hui contemporaine et la
confusion du numérique et de la 5g c'est
là le danger le progrès qu'est ce que
c'est pour pour ses courses et ses
marchands de 5 g qui nous développe
comme argument que ça va nous permettre
notamment
je prends cet exemple le déploiement de
voitures autonomes alors c'est les
grands chantres de l'innovation la
voiture autonome qu'est ce que c'est
c'est des voitures qui se passe
quasiment de leurs conducteurs et qui se
suivent les unes derrière les autres à
vitesse constante sur des voies qui leur
sont dédiés et bien c'est ces grands
visionnaires en fait ils sont en train
de réinventer le train qui existe depuis
plusieurs plusieurs siècles donc c'est
pas ça le progrès c'est pas ça que doit
nous amener le numérique le progrès
c'est la fibre optique dans tous les
foyers de france ce que disait monsieur
cyril davant sur le fait que le réseau
cellulaire il est depuis 96 on nous
promet que tout le monde va être
couverts 1996 là les premiers forfaits
pour les particuliers 24 ans après il ya
des zones blanches partout donc les
premiers sur la scène gl sont elles
seront absolument pas tenu et moi ce que
je dis aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut
aujourd'hui le gouvernement se mettre en
capacité de dire déroulée la fibre
optique dans tous les foyers et que la
start up nation qui se vantait être le
comble du modernisme n'arrive pas à
faire mieux que les ptt qui dans les
années 80 ont développé et déployé
partout dans toutes les zones de france
les plus reculées le téléphone dans
chaque foyer qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
capables de déployer la fibre optique
donc vous voyez il ya cette question
aussi de caisse que nous de quoi nous
parlons de qu'est ce que nous entendons
par progrès est donc là je pense qu'il
ya vraiment aussi cette confusion qui
est entretenue à dessein pour essayer de
faire en sorte que quelques opérateurs
essayent de de créer des marchés de
toutes pièces des démarches et pour nous
vendre des forfaits des appareils
mobiles des objets connectés
alors que l'on n'a absolument pas besoin
que ça n'est pas un progresse
actuellement pour notre vie de tous les
jours cyril dalle mongoloïde prud'hommes
vous dit qu'au fond
la 5g c'est juste aller un petit peu
plus vite et que ça servira pas à grand
chose dans le quotidien des français et
que finalement c'est aussi une histoire
de gros sous vous répondez quoi je suis
partiellement d'accord avec lui il ya
une histoire de gros sous il a rappelé
que les licences de 4g ont rapporté en
2011 3 de 2,8 milliards d'euros et en
2015 3,5 milliards d'euros
il ya une histoire de gros sous la halle
et les licences de 2,5 g vont être
pourrait croire ou être monnayée donc il
ya effectivement une histoire de gros
sous il ya le renouvellement du des
smartphones et du des objets connectés
la vente des objets connectés
donc c'est très clairement une question
économique mais ni caution économique
mondiale après dire qu'il n'y aura aucun
progrès avec la fac j'ai c'est pas la
réalité non plus c'est une technologie
qui a son avance et avantages notamment
la communication avec les objets
connectés à qui sera beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus simple et beaucoup plus
rapide
c'est une évidence après c'était les cds
était chouette société effectivement à
l'utilité des objets connectés
voilà c'est un choix de société en fait
est de ne voir des revers fois autant
est ce que l'on souhaite
comme société demain effectivement le
numérique vous pouvez en faire plein de
choses vous pouvez contrôler un veau
population où vous pouvez aussi faire de
la recherche
dégel des séquences d adn et soigner les
gens la question la question de 2,2 de
fond on l'a bien compris quelle société
on veut pour demain loïc prud'hommes
pour conclure il nous reste quelques
secondes pour conclure ce face à face
oui pour dire que c'est effectivement un
choix de société que la question
sanitaire et finalement pas la question
centrale
contrairement ce que vous aviez annoncé
en disant voilà parce que on sait bien
que de ça on saura on n'aura jamais le
fin mot de l'histoire et je voudrais
quand même signaler à ce sujet là que la
france sera bien incapable de 2 c'est à
dire de documenter les problèmes
sanitaires puisque nous n'avons pas de
registre des cancers notamment dans
notre pays où ils sont très partiel et
qui couvrent à peine 20% du territoire
et donc cette question sera jamais
tranchée donc c'est bien une question
politique du type de société que nous
voulons et ce que nous voulons rentrer
dans un consumérisme effréné moment nous
sommes dans un mur environnementales et
climatiques ou est-ce qu'on veut
justement plutôt aller vers de la
frugalité et ralentir réellement pour
vivre mieux ensemble sur sur d'autres
d'autres valeurs que celui de consommer
sans fin pour avoir une apparence du
bonheur un grand merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté le débat en direct sur
rt france merci à vous loïc prud'hommes
je rappelle que vous êtes députée elle
est fille de la 3e circonscription de
gironde
merci à vous cyril d'allemands est
chercheur à l'institut thomas more